damien coquille on vous retrouve damien
dans cinq minutes tout de suite c'est le
décryptage
avec vos armes et le charrier ce matin
bonjour armelle bonjour polinois la
guerre en ukraine rebat les cartes en
europe les premiers ministres slovène
tchèques et polonais était hier à kiev
ils ont rencontré le président zelensky
dans une ville évidemment sous très
forte tension quel est le sens de cette
visite une visite pour le moins
surprenante de la part de deux pays
trois pays avec la pologne la slovénie
et la tchéquie qui ont connu
effectivement ce qui était chez elle
l'emprise communiste
allag à l'époque avant la
après quand il y avait encore l'urss je
t'en prie mes mots et donc du coup qui
se retrouvent j'allais dire presque en
cousinage en quelque sorte allé voir le
président zelensky peut-être lui
raconter comment est-ce qu'on passe
justement d'un pays qui à un moment
donné doit s'émanciper et se retrouve
avec l'union européenne et l'otan comme
alliance aujourd'hui quoi qu'il en soit
ces trois hommes qui sont arrivés dans
une ville qui aujourd'hui est bombardée
qui a vu hier un journaliste de fox news
et son fixeur être tué par un tir et
bien tout cela montre la dangerosité
effectivement qu'il y avait à aller se
rendre ainsi à côté du président de nine
ce qui certes la route du sud est
toujours ouverte à kiev on est toujours
dans l'attenté d'une arrivée des troupes
russes mais il n'empêche que ça reste
dangereux et que cette image de
communication était la bienvenue pour le
président c'est minsky une image de
communication qui était pas forcément
celle de l'union européenne on ne sait
pas évidemment si tout le monde était au
courant lorsqu'il en avait discuté à
versailles officiellement oui
officieusement non les gens avaient
l'air d'être moins jeu courant contre
leur poser la question parmi les trois
représentants qui étaient hier à kiev
peut-être il y en a un pour lesquels
c'était plus important encore c'est le
premier ministre polonais dont le pays
est en première ligne au propre comme au
figuré la pologne est effectivement
accueil des réfugiés beaucoup un mignon
5 aujourd'hui de réfugiés qui arrivent
de la province voisine puisque l'ukraine
jouxtant fait une grande partie de la
pologne donc ce n'est plus facile pour
les habitants un peu débordé
effectivement par ce nombre de personnes
qui arrivent mais qu'elle avait déjà
aussi accueilli en 2014 donc forcément
il ya une discussion avec le président
hélène ski à ce propos là et puis
surtout aussi la pologne qui a fait tant
rêver l'ukraine n'a parce que justement
les populations sont si proches entre
l'ouest de l'ukraine et la frontière
polonaise qu'elles ont vu des
populations qui vivaient comme elle
s'enrichir que d'un seul coup les
paysans ont pu voir comment est-ce que
de l'autre côté eh bien il avait du
matériel automatisé qu'ils avaient des
routes qui était construite par l'argent
effectivement européen que l'on avait
derrière des bibliothèques des écoles
des hôpitaux quoi le faire et fait rêver
d'avoir une liberté d'avoir internet
tout ça a effectivement poussé à cette
envie de démocratie et cette envie de
rentrer dans l'union européenne
et de l'autre côté comment est ce que le
kremlin peuvent voir ce genre
d'initiatives européennes évidemment
vladimir poutine observe tout tout ce
qui se passe parce qu'il veut comprendre
comment est ce que les uns et les autres
sont capables d'avancer il a fortement
été surpris de la cohérence j'allais
dire européenne sur les sanctions ou sur
la question des réfugiés qui normalement
avait plutôt divisée des 27 la has a été
pendant longtemps un bloc uni alors
cette fois ci cette escapade à 3
forcément lui attirer le regard à 3 est
ce que cela veut dire qu'il ya un biais
à 3 est ce que cela veut dire qu'il ya
des pays européens qui ont envie d'aller
un peu plus loin vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
qui voudrait vraiment dans ces cas-là
faire quelque chose vis-à-vis de
l'ukraine et qui ne serait pas tout à
fait suivi par les autres pays européens
on peut bien se douter effectivement que
ça intéresse fortement le kremlin tout
comme va l'intéresser la réunion de
l'otan qui va se tenir demain soir là
c'est une alliance stratégique c'est une
alliance militaire il ya les américains
derrière il n'y aura pas de fausses
notes et quand même entendre qu'elles
sont lily deforce des uns et des autres
voir si c'est cohérent ou si on peut
commencer à déceler des ambiguïtés pour
lui effectivement c'est la stratégie la
plus importante merci beaucoup armelle
c'était votre décryptage on retrouve
damien ok maintenant pour la suite du
journal